in ukraine there is renewed talk of
creating a humanitarian corridor yet
again
that would allow safe passage for
civilians trapped in marijuana starting
today
most previous attempts have failed it
comes as officials have found a second
mass grave outside the besieged southern
port city satellite images reveal a hole
that appears to have space for at least
a thousand bodies
last night ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky warned that russia has its
sights set on far more countries than
just ukraine chris livesay is following
developments from the ukrainian capital
of kiev chris good morning
good morning jeff russian troops in
mariupol are once again bombing and
trying to storm the steel mill
protecting 1 000 civilians and a group
of soldiers ukraine says this after
vladimir putin himself ordered his
troops to stop in what now appears to
have been a cynical bluff
a once thriving city now robbed of life
save for the bleak salvation of a steel
mill
soldiers and civilians have been hiding
underground from the hell above for
nearly two months
we want to go home we want to see the
sun says this little girl for russia
this is called victory a horrific sign
of what may come in eastern ukraine now
at the center of vladimir putin's war
but his recent defeats in and around
kiev expose unresolved weaknesses
starting with russia's armored vehicles
you can see some
large holes yeah those are huge
ukrainian military expert yuris banotsky
walks me through a graveyard of russian
tanks in the city of bucha it's not a
good military leadership if you're
losing so many men and so many
so much equipment
to date ukraine says russia has lost
close to 3 000 armored vehicles but only
half in combat as for the other half
they were abandoned or ran out of fuel
and it's finders keepers for these
farmers their personnel is not properly
trained their commanding officers are
not
able to plan their offensive operations
russia may have one of the world's
biggest militaries but quantity doesn't
equal quality says russian propaganda
expert marco supreme who shows me a
telephone from a captured russian tank
seriously
i mean it looks like it came out of a
museum
this is a country that has nuclear
weapons
this is this is this is comedy gold for
somebody how is this a symbol of power
russia's power is now being tested in
the eastern donbass region gone is the
urban environment around kiev that gave
ukraine's fighters defensive shelter now
it's open to rain and long-range
artillery including dozens of howitzers
ukraine is now getting from the u.s dana
chris haunting words from earlier in
that piece that young girl saying that
she just wants to see the sun
thank you very much